doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is finally here and it's as
trippy as the trailers suggest so what
was going on in that illuminati scene
and what's up with that mid-credits
cameo keep watching to find out
steven strange spends much of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness in
a state of distress the multiverse it's
dangerous by the end of the film he
seems to have mostly resolved what was
troubling him he manages to hold out
long enough for wanda maxim off to see
the error of her ways set a lot of
things right and even keep america
chavez safe from harm throughout their
adventures together but he's also as
wong points out at the end of the film
used an alternate universe darkhold to
dreamwalk and possessed his own
alternate universe corpse we know from
steven's multiverse journey that holding
on to the dark hold even a little too
long can corrupt someone's mind we saw
it with wanda and with the alternate
stephen strange who admitted to killing
his various multiversal selves along his
path to madness our stephen seems fine
right up until the very last shot when
he collapses in pain on the streets of
new york and reveals a third eye in his
forehead like the one his evil variant
had by the mid-credits sequence he seems
fine with that third eye suggesting he's
adjusted to its presence is stephen okay
or are we witnessing the master of the
mystic arts falling from grace just like
versions of him from other universes
it'll be fascinating to see what the
next adventure holds for a man who faces
so many threats not just to his body but
to his sanity
much of multiverse of madness deals with
pre-existing marvel cinematic universe
characters but it does introduce one
major key player america chavez a young
woman with the power to punch open
portals to other universes and can thus
navigate the entire multiverse with a
swing of her fist when we first meet
america she's on the run as the scarlet
witch works to corner her and steal her
power for herself by the end of the film
with the scarlet witch problem seemingly
solved america has settled down in the
mcu proper learning magic at camara taj
under the tutelage of wong and seemingly
embracing the kind of home she's found
among the superheroes all of this primes
america for future adventures in the mcu
whether she's fighting alongside dr
strange or meeting other heroes along
the way there's still plenty for her to
do in a very personal way including
searching for her two mothers after she
accidentally knocked them through a
portal as a girl but as a fighter in her
own right there's even more potential in
the comics america is a key member of
the superhero team known as the young
avengers which also includes characters
like kate bishop aka hawkeye since kate
is alive and well in the mcu already it
would be welcome and understandable to
see those two team up sometime soon
whatever she ends up doing though
america has a bright future
in spiderman no way home we learn that
wong is actually the sorcerer supreme
because he was around while stephen
strange vanished during the blip leaving
him in charge by default it seemed like
a bit of a throwaway joke but by the
time of multiverse of madness it's clear
that it's far from a gag wang takes his
work seriously something we've known
since we met him back in the first
doctor strange film but not just because
he's a serious person he clearly carries
the burden of being the sorcerer supreme
in a dignified courageous way and it
shows through his actions in the film
even when the fight gets more personal
and when stephen is forced to separate
from his friend and colleague wong
fights on though it sometimes feels
hopeless he just keeps marshalling the
forces of magic in the mcu to combat the
threat of the scarlet witch in her
darkhold by the end of the film he's
proven himself a survivor and he's won a
new level of respect from doctor strange
himself now it falls to wong to attempt
to rebuild the magical order of things
in the mcu with so many sorcerers taken
down during the battle he's in charge of
replenishing the ranks no pressure then
and based on how well he's handled
everything else it seems all those
beginner sorcerers are in very good
hands for much of doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness we're dealing with
a character who looks and sounds like
wanda maximoff but it's not quite the
wanda we know instead she's the scarlet
witch now the long prophecied magic user
first introduced in one division who has
taken on an all-consuming quest to be
reunited with her lost children billy
and tommy this is going to be fun the
scarlet witch means well of course but
the madness caused by continued use of
the darkhold has corrupted her mind
making grief over the loss of her
children into a power-hungry drive to go
through anyone and anything to get what
she wants
that makes her a terrifying yet
sympathetic villain figure who only
really stops when she realizes how
frightening she's become not to her
friends but to her own children wanda's
solution is to destroy the darkhold in
all forms that means the book disappears
in every universe but the throne atop
mount wangador in which she's sitting
when she makes her decision also
crumbles with her inside that said we
never see her die it's entirely possible
that wanda is still out there somewhere
waiting for the moment she can continue
her redemptive journey
early on in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness as the scarlet
witch prepares to assault camartage to
capture america chavez wong uses his
influence as sorcerer supreme to turn
the magical sanctuary into a fortress he
brings in all of his students and arms
them with weapons both magical and
non-magical prepares hidden defenses
around the building and even calls in
the leaders of the sanctums in both
london and hong kong to help with the
fight sadly despite all their magical
energy this army of sorcerers is not
enough to hold the scarlet witch back
this means that a key defensive part of
the mcu's core planet has been
compromised and while wong's working
hard to fix that there are
vulnerabilities that the more nefarious
figures in the mcu might be able to
exploit so who will come for the
sorcerers and how long until they
realize they have an opportunity
in one division mcu viewers were
introduced to the concept of the
darkhold a book of magical spells and
secrets that could grant its user untold
power but at the terrible cost of their
sanity by the end of the series the book
was in the hands of wanda maximon and by
multiverse of madness she was using it
to learn dreamwalking the forbidden
magical practice of invading the lives
of others in the multiverse sounds like
a real nightmare
but multiverse of madness also revealed
that the dark hold has an opposite
number the book of vishanti a book of
light magic that has the potential to
unlock even more magical secrets for its
user including how to navigate the
multiverse by the end of the film both
books are severely compromised the book
of vishanti has lost spells while the
darkhold is apparently destroyed in
every universe leaving its secrets
potentially lost forever but anyone
who's been watching the mcu films and
shows for long enough knows that two
great macguffins can't be kept out of
the picture for too long the darkhold
had a secret copy in at least one
universe while the book of vashanti
could potentially exist in others
they're in bad shape right now but we
wouldn't be surprised to see both books
make future mcu appearances in some form
while traveling through the multiverse
stephen strange eventually visits an
alternate earth that includes an
extremely high-tech version of new york
city where he's been taken captive by
that universe's sorcerer supreme mordow
the illuminati will see you stephen
mordo eventually reveals that he's a
member of the illuminati a secret
society of heroes that includes reed
richards played by john krasinski
captain marvel played by lashana lynch
captain peggy carter patrick stewart's
charles xavier from the x-men and black
bolt the scene is obviously noteworthy
for the sheer number of cameos it packs
into the film by the end of the sequence
that earth's illuminati are in shambles
with all but one of them very dead that
means we probably won't hear from this
illuminati again but it definitely
doesn't mean we'll never hear from any
illuminati again the 616 universe
already had a captain america a captain
marvel and a sorcerer supreme but this
scene heavily implies that a 616 version
of reed richards charles xavier and
black bolt are still out there somewhere
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness we met an alternate universe
version of carl mordo a former ally of
strange who became the sorcerer supreme
when that universe is strange was
executed for his sins by the illuminati
this version of mordo is very suspicious
of the prime mcu strange but after a
brief struggle over the fate of the book
of vashanti he basically disappears from
the film left to pick up the pieces in
his world mordo's brief but significant
appearance in this film is of course a
reminder that the main mcu version of
mordo has basically been absent from the
entire narrative since 2016's doctor
strange at the end of that film the
sorcerer who helped train strange grows
disillusioned with the new sorcerer
supreme in quits but it's later revealed
that he's roaming around sapping other
magic users of their powers why
too many saucers
we haven't heard anything from that
version of mordo since perhaps a third
doctor strange adventure will shed some
light on his whereabouts
dr strange and the multiverse of madness
marked the return of several key
characters in steven strange's life but
one of the most interesting was the
inclusion of christine steven's former
surgical and romantic partner who's
moved on with her life in the years
since he became a master of the mystic
arts as the film begins steven is
suiting up to attend her wedding to
another man where she assures steven
that their romance would never have
worked because in her words he always
had to be the one holding the knife the
reunion is of course interrupted by a
giant monster terrorizing new york city
later in the film stephen gets to
continue a version of that conversation
with an alternate universe version of
christine who actually gets to work
helping him in his quest to stop the
scarlet witch though they don't actually
know each other their experiences create
a kind of kindred feeling which allows
stephen to finally say what he's wanted
to say for years that he truly loves
christine in any and all universes it's
a moment of peace and honesty in a
relationship that was otherwise built on
quite a bit of posturing and it feels
like something that allows both of them
to move on from their losses there are
plenty of loose ends in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness but steven
strange's personal journey isn't
necessarily one of them he's solved the
issues at hand in the story made it back
home and even made some kind of peace
until he's confronted in a mid-credit
scene by a mysterious woman in purple
robes played by charlize theron this
woman warns him that another incursion
is happening due in part to his
adventures and that she needs his help
to stop it she even dares him by asking
if he's afraid sending strange headlong
into another dimension for yet another
adventure this woman is clea one of the
first major supporting characters in dr
strange comic's lore raised in the dark
dimension under the watchful eye of
dormammu she eventually becomes the
sorcerer supreme of the dark dimension
and at one point even takes over for
strange as the sorcerer supreme of earth
she's smart powerful and capable of
warping the world of doctor strange
forever we don't yet know exactly where
the next adventure will take steven
strange just yet but with clea at his
side we know it'll be something worth
watching check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]